In the last lecture I showed you this traditional old camera from 1950s.
An important part of this camera is still that it has these lenses that
are used to focus the rays of light into the sensor chamber.
This is a more recent digital SLR, this is the camera used these days.
And of course, it also has a lens.
And one of the things that we will talk about in this lesson is what kinds of
things that a lens like this does.
And of course, it has things like focal length, variety of things of
this lens actually then control the view that we actually get from the image or
from the scene that actually is represented on the image.
And we also talk about things like what sensor sizes these types of
cameras have.
Varieties from digital SLRs to full frame ones
to simple cellphone cameras that we use.
We'll also talk about how images are formed and
also things like perspective projections.
The simple mathematical representations will be introduced to
show you how we can actually go from information in a real 3D world
to what's actually seen inside a camera.